JASON JOEL: Hi, welcome to Next.
My name is Jason Joel,
and I'm a Product Manager
with Google Cloud.
I'm presenting here today
with my peer, Sai Gopalan.
And in this session,
we will deep
dive into the tools and services
to accelerate your migration
to Google Cloud.
There are several
motivators that
lead customers to
migrate to the cloud
and modernize their
applications and infrastructure.
Many customers begin by
wanting to use the cloud
to increase the
speed of innovation
and address customer
requirements faster.
But often, the
project is initially
justified by an
impending financial need,
like an upcoming hardware
refresh, a significant business
event, such as an acquisition,
or an upcoming deadline,
like an expiring
data center contract.
But it turns out migrating
and modernization
to the cloud is hard.
Enterprise migration
projects often
face delays and go over-budget.
But this is typically
because customers do not
understand the applications
that they are trying to migrate.
They do not have
a good plan that
includes moving
all of their data,
and they generally
underestimate the scale.
At Google, we have a proven
four-step methodology
to help our customers and
meet them where they are,
and accelerate their path to
the Google Cloud platform.
Actually, it's not
four linear steps,
but this is more
of a process that
will be followed iteratively
throughout the migration
journey.
The first step is
the assessment phase.
And for this assessment
phase, Google
has a tool called StratoZone.
And StratoZone enables
you to do five things
as part of your assessment.
First and foremost, it helps
you discover what workloads,
applications, and
virtual machines that you
have that you want to
migrate to the Cloud,
and build an inventory as a
place to start, a baseline.
The second thing it
does is it evaluates
each of your workloads for
its suitability for the cloud,
gives you a Cloud
Fit Score, and helps
you identify what
remediations you may need
to take in order to move it.
The third part of the
StratoZone process
is optimizing your
consumption plan
and identifying where
are the best places
to move a particular
application to Google.
Google offers many services,
and it's not always obvious
where the best
location is to move
and would give you the
biggest impact for your money.
The fourth step is
actually providing you
with an ROI, a real plan, a
return on your investment paper
that you can share
with your enterprise,
and share with your executives
and your stakeholders
to get an idea of what the
return on their investment
will be, and the
benefits they will
gain from moving to the cloud.
And the last step of the
StratoZone consumption plan
is developing this to
provide you with insights
into what you should
do first, second,
and third in your journey.
Let's look at some of the key
features of the StratoZone Data
Collector in itself.
It's agentless, and
it does not require
you to install any software in
each of your virtual machines
or on your physical machines.
All the information
you send is encrypted
in transit and at rest.
It's very lightweight, so
it doesn't put any burden
on your environment.
And in fact, the data
that it transfers
is roughly less than
400 kilobytes in size.
You have the option
to anonymize any data
that you think might
be sensitive, including
IP addresses and machine names.
And it's overall not intrusive.
You can control the
scope of the discovery
that you run from a
single application,
to a single data center, to a
multi-data center or migration.
One of my peers,
[INAUDIBLE],, will now
give you a short demo
on how StratoZone works.
SPEAKER 2: StratoZone
assessments
can scale globally with
multiple data collections
feeding data from various
customer locations.
The assessment relies on
inventory and telemetry data,
and is conducted within
the StratoZone portal.
All data is encrypted
in transit and at rest.
No actual business
confidential data
is collected, such as data
classified as PCI or HIPAA.
Once the assessment
collection has begun,
you will be able to see
the results populate
within the StratoZone portal.
Results include overall
utilization levels,
age of the machines, details
about operating systems,
and cloud migration
compatibility scoring,
among others.
You will also be able to
review detailed inventory
in each machine's detail,
such as its name, IP address,
and configuration specs.
You will be able to
further drill down
into utilization,
installed software,
and running processes.
Network connectivity
maps will be
available for any point-to-point
detected connections.
They can be viewed
in graphical form,
as well as in the table form,
which represents details
about source and target
IPs, ports, and processes,
such as SQL Server,
in this case,
responsible for the
connection socket.
Detailed pricing
views are available
for each assessed location,
application group, or migration
group.
Within the groups, machines
are evaluated individually
based on the
recorded utilization
and user-defined
right-sizing profiles.
Each machine's
cost breakdown can
be viewed in detail to
determine compute, storage,
and egress costs.
Pricing can be generated for a
variety of different catalogs,
including GC predefined types,
custom shapes, sole tenancy,
and [? GCV. ?] Committed
and sustained discounts
are included in the calculation.
Custom discounting can also
be defined by the user.
Pricing can also be tailored
to relevant GCP regions.
StratoZone also stores
industry benchmark costs
for operating
on-premises data centers,
which can be used in
comparisons to devise the most
suitable pricing scenarios.
At any point in the
assessment, a customizable deck
can be generated in the
reporting dashboard.
It can be fully customized to
include the relevant workload
groups, optimizations, pricing
catalogs, and discounts.
This assessment
summary can serve
as a leave-behind customer
deliverable and a proposal.
This deck will cover
the assessment approach
and findings, along with
pricing information.
Findings represented
for all assets
or broken down by
user-configurable groups.
Solutions such as
databases and app engines
will be identified, along
with potential GCP targets.
TCO reports will be generated to
provide meaningful comparisons.
JASON JOEL: After completing
the assessment stage,
you enter the planning phase.
Google has a pricing
methodology that
helps make initial progress
quickly, reduce risk, and stay
on budget.
StratoZone can help you arrange
migration candidates in order
of priority, based on business
impact and the migration
effort that's required.
A large migration
will have many waves,
with velocity increasing
as the migrations progress
and experience in the
organization is gained.
By categorizing your workloads
in the waves based on these two
parameters, you can iterate,
learn from those iterations,
and then optimize your process.
With StratoZone's
Cloud Readiness Report,
you can see which assets
are high-, medium-,
and low-fit for
moving to the Cloud.
This is based on characteristics
such as capacity, performance,
age, operating system, and
other machine-based attributes.
Now Sai will explain
the tools that Google
has to help you with the
Migrate Phase of your journey.
SAI GOPALAN: Thank you, Jason.
Hi.
I'm Sai, and I'm a Product
Manager with Google Cloud.
Let's jump right in.
When we look at
migrations, customers
have specific paths to
migrating to Google Cloud.
Each migration path
has an increasing level
of transformation,
and therefore change.
And we have a number of tools
that can help you with that.
For example, in addition
to moving your specialized
workloads or VMs to the
Google Cloud bare metal
Solution, or Google Cloud VMware
Engine, or Compute Engine,
or to GKE, you may want to move
your unstructured archival data
from an on-premises file
system to the cloud.
And we offer a few
options, including
a fully-online storage transfer
service and a dedicated
transfer appliance that can be
shipped to your data center.
Let's look at a few
tools in more detail
in the subsequent section.
The first tool is Migrate
for Compute Engine
that's delivered as a service.
Our latest version delivers a
Google-managed cloud service
that enables simple,
friction-less,
and large-scale enterprise
migration of virtual machines
to Compute Engine with
minimal downtime and risk.
Hundreds of VMs,
fast-to-start, this
is a replication-based
tool, which means
that it's predictable as well.
API driven and integrated
into your Google Cloud Console
for ease of use, you can do
your end-to-end migration
through the Google
Cloud Console.
This service uses
agentless replication
to copy data without
manual intervention
and without VPN requirements.
It also enables you to launch
non-disruptive validations
of your VMs prior to cutover.
You can rapidly migrate
a single application
or execute a sprint with 100
systems using Migration Groups
with confidence.
There are six easy steps.
You enable your API.
You deploy a
migration connector,
on-board and
initiate replication,
set your VM target, perform
your test, and cut over.
Users can test their
workloads pre-cutover
by creating clones
of the workload
from the replicated
data in the cloud
without disrupting
the source workload.
It also adapts the migrating
workloads automatically
to run natively in the cloud.
And it includes network
setting and installation
of cloud agents for seamless
integration with Cloud Services
post-migration as well.
It supports migrating
workloads to different target
configurations on the fly.
For example, users can
test-clone a workload
in project A while doing a
cutover of the same workload
to project B. Let us
now hear from Rackspace
and their experience
with this tool.
MATT RICHINS: The tool that
we love the most at Rackspace
is Google's Migrate
for Compute Engine.
It's a super-easy tool for
taking your environment that's
on-prem in a VMware environment,
and migrating that to Google.
But what's amazing is that
it's not like some tools,
where it's like, hey,
here's your limitations,
and we can only do A or
B. They can do everything.
It allows our customers
to plan properly.
It let's our IT resources
focus on running their company
and helping their end
users, while we just
use the tool to do what
it's supposed to do,
which is migrate.
And then we're done.
It's very easy.
We love it.
I cannot say enough good things
about how well it works with
the technology environments.
SAI GOPALAN: What a great video
from our partner, Rackspace.
Now, Migrate for Compute
Engine enables users
to group VMs based on
their needs and scenarios,
and execute migration
operations on a group level,
as well as a subset
of the group.
This flexibility allows for you
to edit the migration details
for one or many of
the VMs in the group,
and perform replication, test
cloning, and cutover, as well.
Let us now look at
the lifecycle of a VM.
It starts with
on-boarding the VM, which
means telling the tool that
it's ready to start replication.
And once you start replication,
an initial sync happens.
All of this without
disruption to the source VMs.
This is followed by continuous
replication thereafter.
You can also perform
non-disruptive testing
with test cloning.
There is no disruption
to on-premises VM.
And it's always a good idea
to validate that a VM will
run correctly in the cloud.
Finally, you cut
over to the Cloud
during a scheduled
maintenance window.
This is when the source
VM is powered off,
a final sync of the VM
data is done to the Cloud,
and that's it.
Let us now look at a
quick demo of this tool.
In this demo, I will walk
through a quick overview
of Migrate for Compute
Engine that's delivered
as a Google Managed Service.
This means that you
do not have to manage
the lifecycle of the tool.
I'll cover the sources,
the Migration tab,
and how you can perform
bulk operations with groups.
Here we see the main
dashboard of Migrate
for Compute Engine that's
completely integrated
into our Cloud console.
It shows an overview of
the migrations, the events,
the sources, the
groups, and the target.
Let's go to the Sources tab.
In the Sources tab,
I can see that I
have multiple on-prem
data centers that
act as sources of
virtual machines
that I want to migrate from.
For each one of these
sources, I can actually
see that I have the VM
inventory cached in the system.
This allows you to execute
end-to-end migrations
without ever
leaving the console.
Migrate for Compute Engine
uses replication to migrate
the virtual machine's data
over to the destination,
or the target.
As you can see over here,
there are virtual machines
that are ready for replication.
There are virtual
machines that are active,
which means that there is
periodic replication that's
ongoing in the background.
And there is a virtual machine
that's already been cutover.
Let's go into the Migration tab.
This is the place where I do
all of my migration operations.
I can see the status of
all my migrating VMs.
I can go into the
Info panel and edit
the details of my
migration virtual machine.
Here I've selected w12core.
And what I can do over here
is I can edit the landing
zone of the migrating VM.
And I can also select a VM and
perform migration operations.
Actions include starting
the replication,
pausing the replication,
resuming the replication,
finalizing the replication.
It also includes testing
the virtual machine
with no impact to the
source VM in order
to validate that the workload in
the cloud is running correctly.
And finally, cutting over
with minimal downtime.
Many customers also want
to migrate virtual machines
in bulk.
The Group feature
allows you to do that.
Here I see that I have actually
grouped three virtual machines
in a group called myapp-1.
Groups enable you to
execute operations in bulk,
such as bulk editing of
migration details, test
clone, and cutover.
Here I can see that I can select
all my VMs or a subset of them,
and perform bulk editing
of migration details
on all of them.
I can also do test
cloning and cutover
for all of these at one
go, or a subset of these.
This brings us to the end
of a quick overview demo.
Now many customers want to
migrate their VMware workloads
to a native vSphere environment
running in the cloud
to increase their
agility and reduce costs.
Google Cloud VMware
Engine solves this problem
and gives you a fast-forward
to your journey to the cloud.
It is one of the fastest
ways to migrate your VMware
applications to the cloud.
And VMware HCX is the
tool that enables this.
It's provided as part
of VMware Engine,
and it abstracts the
underlying infrastructure
and offers many
options, including
hot, cold, and warm
migration options in bulk.
Now, many customers also want
to fast-forward to modernizing
their applications.
With Migrate for Anthos,
you can transform your VMs
to containers that
is managed by Anthos.
With migrate for GKE, you
can transform your VMs
to containers that's managed
by GKE in either Standard Mode,
or Autopilot Mode.
Finally, you can
transform your VMs
to containers that's
managed by Cloud Run
so you can get started with the
server-less architecture right
off the bat.
Once more, this happens in
a simple six-step process.
You qualify a VM, configure
the processing cluster
to examine the source VM,
and create a migration plan
that you then review
and customize.
Then you use the
processing cluster
to simply execute
the migration plan,
and generate your
deployment YAMLs,
your container images,
your data volumes.
You verify that the workload
is migrated correctly
by running some tests, and
finally, deploy the container
artifacts to your testing,
staging, and production
clusters.
You can migrate from VMware
on-premises, AWS, Azure,
or even within GCE.
Now once you migrated,
you want to be
able to keep optimizing
your environment.
We have a tool called
VM Manager that
allows you to manage
large fleets of VMs
running Windows or Linux.
You can manage your OS patches,
perform compliance reporting
on OS patches, install, remove,
and maintain agents, apps,
and configurations,
or in other words,
manage your OS
configurations, and also use
this service to collect
runtime OS information.
We also have a technology
called Activist Assist.
Now, Activist Assist
is a portfolio
of tools that uses data,
intelligence, and machine
learning to reduce
cloud complexity
and administrative toil, making
it easy for you to optimize
your cloud environment.
Whether you're interested in
security, cost, networking,
compute, data, or operations, we
have the intelligence for you.
Some new Active Assist
features include
idle resource recommendations,
compute committed use discount
recommendations, and more.
So what are you waiting for?
You can start with a
quick assessment that's
offered at no additional cost.
You will receive a
detailed inventory
of your virtual and physical
server assets and database
estate, and a
customized total cost
of ownership report for
moving to the cloud,
as well as a detailed
end-to-end migration plan.
This brings us to the
end of this presentation.
On behalf of Jason
and I, we thank you
for watching this session.